[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he insists that you call him hall of
famer
whenever you introduce him he's michael
wilbon from pardon the interruption
covering the nba joining us from
milwaukee
hey hall of famer how are you today okay
first of all he does not insist oh you
don't
oh everybody you said wilbon wanted to
be called
that's what that's what i thought but
he's not like that so that's what he's
doing
under the bus just now oh my goodness
no don't insist upon that um
i'm close to milwaukee dan i'm 88 miles
away from milwaukee in chicago
pritzy i gave you two songs for two i
said how does wilbon want to be
introduced and where is he joining us
from
not gonna make the all-star game i was
just talking about my vacation
uh where i went to montana fly fishing
do you got a uh do you got a
like an adventure vacation you've ever
taken
no well chrissy just asked me that he
said
what dangerous thing have you done like
nothing ever
i mean no no no no i've been i've been
to montana but i've not
i've not uh if i went there today dan i
would go with golf clubs
trying to find that same course that
those guys played you know last week
but no there's no danger i've never been
fly fishing
uh went fishing once when i was 11 years
old with my uncle bill in chicago
and vowed never to go fishing again and
i've kept that
well you're not an outdoorsman like me
you're not a man
okay
[Laughter]
i'll take your word for that um uh what
golf is somehow
less yeah less you know less than yeah
yes how many times
are are you okay i've known you a long
time we've known you a long time
i have never heard you tell fly fishing
stories
we've never we've never done that once
every 20 years
yeah the last time i went fly fishing
was
in british columbia in 1989.
what made you do it this time uh
i had to man up a little bit i was
getting a little soft
you know you know you know how you you
writers used to call
us you know talking hairdos we still do
yeah even though i would love to call
you a talking hairdo you just
you don't got any hair that's right yes
actually i fall outside that
categorization
um before i get to the bucks and the
suns
the united states lost to nigeria yeah
okay
should we care about this as we uh head
into the olympics with this team i know
there's some guys still playing in the
finals but and it's
and it's a friendly but the united
states lost to nigeria
in basketball i was sitting i was here
in chicago
two nights ago when that game was going
on and i was at the the wnba game
um mystics and the sky i wanted to
go and see my friend candace parker play
and i'm with
a bunch of guys who have been sports
writers i think all in tv now
all of whom you know you know jay adande
david aldridge mark spears vinnie
goodwill you
you know the whole the crew sean powell
and we're sitting there and we're
monitoring this score right we're
monitoring that game
we're at a game and we're going each guy
turns to the other
and goes oh my god we're losing to
nigeria with
you know seven minutes left with four
minutes left with 30 seconds left
and indicate the question from each one
of us to the other was
how big a deal is this like should we
care about this
is it a friendly is it an exhibition is
it a warm-up is it practice
is kevin durant really playing and so
even as you ticked off the answers kind
of yes yes yes
i think it's important because we never
even
remember remember how crazy the
reporting of the scrimmage loss
the dream team lost like chris webber
and grant hill
and bobby hurley and adams i don't even
know who i was on that team
those guys were the headliners and we
cared about it
and those guys jordan barkley magic
bird they they wanted us to care because
they cared
they cared enough to threaten the lives
of those college players
right and said you will be shut out
summarily
tomorrow in which they essentially did
they cared and they wanted us to care
so using that criteria dan we got what's
so what's the care scale
like is it a seven is it's not a nine
i'm gonna go better than five though
what about you yeah i'm up there with it
but i think it's really a testament to
the rest of the world
that how important basketball is and you
can go back to the dream team
and and what the the dream team birthed
around the world
and i think we've seen that i think
you've seen that with the
you know players from europe who come
over you know the greek freak
i don't i don't know what that impact
had on him
or luka doncic um you know the joker
like these guys who
you know probably were young if if they
were even born
and watching that dream team and what
that dream team meant getting videos
getting vhs tapes in in these other
countries i mean that
the importance of that is not lost on me
so as much as i'd like to say the united
states went through the motions
you know give credit to nigeria that
this really meant something to them
and dan i i've been on this crusade
that the all-star game which has become
a complete and utter waste of
time the nba all-star game waste of time
i don't want to see people choosing
upsides and going shirts and skins i
don't give a damn about that
the nba for some reason is studiously
avoiding
having us versus the world if we had
that game
even the last five years okay just
thinking we had the game this coming
all-star game right
look at look at the look at the bigs
you've got just the front line you
mentioned giannis of course
embiid joker the mvp of the league
if you just had the three of them and
you've got don jacou you've already
mentioned
and you've got jamal murray okay is that
a starting five you'd like to see
play against an all-star team of u.s
pedal of course it is
and i don't know if the league is
embarrassed that it might that the
u.s team even though the the nba
all those guys belong to that fraternity
why won't they do it
why won't they do something that you
could actually sink your teeth into
all-star week
as opposed to the junk that it's junk
it's just it's an exhibition of dunking
we already got a dunk contest
let's see the best in the world because
you know there's pride they'd want to do
it if
you put those those 10 guys out there
those 24 guys out there
they're going to want to win and the
all-star weekend becomes
something valuable instead of the junk
that the game the game is junk
but you look the testament to the rest
of the world i am 100
with you on that and look at again i
just named five guys off top of my head
yeah look at
all the players that you have coming
along the young canadian players in
addition to jamal murray the young
african players
going back to your question about
nigeria i think this is a significant
development
and i'd like to see it explored more by
the nba
he's uh hall of famer michael wilbon
espn's pardon the interruption co-host
and of course uh
part of espn abc's nba coverage
giannis is always interesting and it's
not like he's polarizing i think people
want to make his style
polarizing or his star status polarizing
and i always wondered about this when i
watched wilt chamberlain play
i never said gosh i don't know why he's
not taking jumpers
when i when i watched shaq i never said
gosh
he's not taking jumpers when i watch
kareem
i never said boy he doesn't do anything
other than a sky hook
why is it that we can't just like the
greek freak
can be dominating i don't need him to
shoot a three to keep the defense honest
um you know ben simmons has to learn to
shoot because he's on the perimeter and
he handles the ball
i want the greek freak down low
dominating
like i'm okay with that mike every
possession
dan you know this means we're old that
first of all let's start with that let's
just let's just declare you and i
are that's assumed
we're philosophically aligned completely
so okay here i i don't want him shooting
threes i do want him to develop
a 14 to 16 foot shot so the wall they
put up
he can do something else other than
maybe pick up two or three offensive
files a game
trying to crash through it so that's as
far as i go otherwise i am entirely with
you
um his team's shortcomings to this point
are not
his fault at all when you go 42 and 13 a
couple of nights
don't tell me what more that guy needs
to do somebody else needs to do more
and i think it's polarizing damn because
we've got this thing which is fairly
attractive otherwise positionless
basketball
i do applaud that and the versatility it
brings to the game for others
but my god this guy is a great player
he's a legitimate two-time
mvp the shortcomings seem to belong more
to
his coach and his teammates and i don't
need to see him do any more i need to
see him do what he did last night in
fact
when he wanders out there and shoots the
three he hurts his team his team is less
is less and this is just dumb the fact
that the bucks may come out wednesday
night and go out
and hoist threes and be down by 18.
because this is what they've done the
whole postseason they play a specific
way
you know it works it works to the tune
of championship
level play and it's just kendrick
perkins
you could say kendrick my man kendrick
was a bit strong when he said the
dumbest team ever in the finals
but but dan they do so they do things
you just can't understand
what they're doing because they've
proven they can win
this way kicking your butt in the paint
with that guy leading the way oh but
it's not good enough even for them so
i i i'm with you i'm with you i don't
get it i think it hurts
well look i chris middleton and drew
holiday are
you know they're not guys that are
you're going to build around but they
need to be
complementary figures that i just want
giannis
down low i don't want him handling the
ball bringing it up the floor
because you can set up that wall that
miami did last year
in the playoffs if i have him down low
okay now what are you going to do and if
middleton and
holliday hit shots yes that to me makes
them formidable
if everybody stands around for giannis
to dribble down and then try to break
through
then you're not getting good basketball
if i put him down low
ayton's got to guard him you put him in
foul trouble
and then i got middleton and holliday
who were going to be single covered and
maybe at times
you know left alone that to me would be
you know my approach to this for the
milwaukee bucks
and that is the approach i sat with uh
both
both games in phoenix it's that between
isaiah thomas and avery johnson
and you know again i'm sitting with guys
who now would be called by the entire
basketball
world younger than them old guys they're
only guys who are you know
great and played with intellect and won
championships
and they said exactly what you're saying
i was waiting for i'm i'm waiting
for them knowing basketball the way they
do to say no it's okay to do this and
they're both and they coached
and they're going oh my god what what is
this
why isn't he here and he's a willing
passer
right and he's a tough guy he's a
legitimate
tough guy who doesn't shy away and so
okay the free throws could be a problem
and maybe that's a problem later
you know in the game not last night but
dan that's that's the milwaukee bucks
conundrum
what how are they going to do what are
they going to do wednesday night and
what are they going to do
in what many presume would be a game
five saturday back in phoenix
another thing that i don't understand is
as much as i
love watching devin booker devin booker
can disappear
on you and you know for a guy who has
that mamba mentality and
kobe was there to mentor him i i just
don't see that
as my and i you know maybe i'm asking
too much but we've seen a guy scored 70
in a game
i just i expect him to be
maybe more consistent in in that just
pressuring the defense there and there
are times he just sort of
floats and gives you a three for 15
night i think
that he hasn't this is his first time on
any stage
his first time i remember this his first
time in the playoffs
and i think he's learning still
the difference between that level of
pressure and becoming that consistent
he had a bad game last night although i
think what happens is
i mean every i mean as great as they are
the the
the level of player above him and more
experience they have bad games too
yeah i mean i'm sure lebron has had a
bad game or two
in a in a series i think i want booker
to have
out of a six game series i want him to
have three great games i think he's done
that
i think he's done that now last night he
had a bad game and now here's what we
got to see
it the star bounces back you know when
kobe's told him famously as he wears
the tattoo to be legendary this is when
you create your legend
this is when you build it now he did it
against the lakers he did it against
denver
he even did it against the clippers
multiple games where he was great yeah
now he did it in games one and two he
didn't do it in game three obviously
if if if devin booker is going to be
that guy that you are talking about and
i believe he
can be did he needs to do that in game
four
uh and and maybe five or four and six
he's got to do that two more times
to get to be the best player on the
floor chris paul's the most important
player
on the floor we're in his jersey that
jersey but he's got to do it to get
them to hoist that trophy and then he's
sort of fulfilling
what kobe thought he could be
the lakers in the off season lebron's
a great recruiter but i don't know
how much maneuverability they have
to be able to recruit if if you're the
lakers
what would you be what would be priority
number one
well you gotta figure out and i don't
know if you can figure this out but the
priority would be
how is anthony davis going to
consistently contribute
and look i love anthony davis right i
mean
his game his pr who he is he i'm
predisposed he's a chicago boy like i am
i love anthony davis
but when people say top five player i'm
like i'm i'm not
i'm not going there because i can name
five i'm gonna take
ahead of him now he's in that next group
and there's no sin in that my god you
could be he's been a championship player
already
but you got to figure out what you're
going to get from him and how frequently
because because i don't believe dan and
i don't know what you believe about this
i don't believe these injuries and
people missing all this time i don't
believe these are one-offs
i believe this is where the league is i
believe they ought to go to a 65-game
schedule which they're not going to do
how reliable can he be going forward
with lebron
he's got to get in shape mike i agree i
agree so so you got to figure you got to
address
that and if you come up with an answer
you think is satisfactory if you're the
lakers brass and
you're lebron okay but if that's not
your answer
then what do you do who's your second
guy you know there's all this buzz out
there now you know i'm around you know
when you're in nba circles my god the
rumors about the nba
trades acquisitions free agency or the
juiciest ones most of them
make no sense but the lakers have so
little flexibility that
that they can't just go and get somebody
they're gonna have to either make a deal
be very creative get anthony davis can
anthony davis play
72 games next year and be anthony davis
well that hasn't happened like all that
often
so i think determining that to the
degree that you can
is the place that the lakers have to
start
would you trade anthony davis for damian
lilly i knew that was going to come up
that's one of those i was talking about
okay my first inclination
is yes but where do you get then okay so
let's say you got damon lebron out there
do you have size do you have i mean i
mean
wings who are six eight and six nine
seem to be growing on trees
and again all you gotta do is go back
and watch nigeria beat the you know
beat the us and that that that friendly
so where do you get that like where
i mean you know they don't have that
otherwise and it seems to me
that dynamic i mean lebron is that
but you you need a couple you can't
just go say well paul george would be a
great fit as a
two and a half or a three let's get him
and he could you can't they don't have
the money they don't
i'm told i was told all week stop they
don't they can't do what you
may be suggesting what about porzingis
for ben simmons well would
is lebron at this point we know lebron
has been patient enough
god the years that lebron led teams to
the finals that didn't have
anywhere near what you're talking about
suggests okay lebron is going to work
with these guys
at this stage is he going to be patient
enough
porzingis plays like 49 he plays fewer
games than anthony davis
but no but if you said philly and and
dallas
now i don't like it just because luke
has always got the ball
and like what what's the complimentary
player
who can play with luca dame not
complimentary but
a shoe like seriously a guy
who can just who can shoot dave dame's
unfair
okay so next level guy um
you know a top 20 player okay cj
mccollum
well well now and see we know cj doesn't
have to have the ball
yeah because we've seen dame have the
ball and that worked to at least the
degree of the conference fine
here's what's going to happen for them
though dan real quickly lucas got to be
more mature
luca right now is like he's like uh
glorified not glorified
he's rasheed wallace in terms of
impact obviously he has the ball he has
more diverse skills and all that
but he's out of control he is completely
immature on the floor
he undermined his own effort in that
series they should have won
because he's screaming at the other
bench because he's up 30 to nine
he is unbelievably immature and they got
to fix that
and then rick carlisle people don't
leave
when a player is great as luca doncic
yeah but they left
so something something else has to be
done there i don't think it's just
player acquisition
but i'm i'm kind of with you there on
who he needs
hey great to talk to you congrats on the
hall of fame
thank you tell todd never introduce me
that way
ever again sir michael wilbon
joining us here have you been knighted
yet
if i can be like nick i'll be united
hey can't you come to a game can't you
bring the whole party to a game like old
times come on
you're turning into tony being in the
attic for you know for the rest of your
life it was fun having you again you
know what mike when the bulls are back
i'm bringing the guys to chicago how's
that there's your guy
there's your guy for luca zach levine
although i don't want to lose zach from
what they're trying to do in chicago so
i strike that thank you mike great to
talk to you again buddy
that's uh michael wilbon espn pardon the
interruption co-host
and uh part of espn abc nba coverage
take a break you got your phone calls
coming up but first it's our play of the
day that's next here on the dan patrick
show